um dr lena brodsky has already mentioned
is the uh director of the tower
bioinformatics research center at
university of haifa um his background is
mathematics and biostatistics but
today he is going to work he's going to
share with us about mathematical
modeling of single-stranded rna viruses
the role of naturally occurring
defective virus genomes
as well as
other topics as well so dr brodsky i
will pass this on to you
okay
can you hear me
yes we can hear you okay
uh okay uh actually i i have two topics
the first one is virology actually we
did it together with professor andina
um
so this is uh
ordinary
differential equation modeling of
uh of an interplay between some
virus
with
defective
genomes defective viral genomes of this
virus which
appear in nature
okay so the defective genome
here's the genome of this virus
flowering virus in general
the
majority of defective genomes actually
eliminate this portion
so uh
structural proteins and ns1 which is
very important because this is it works
in trance and participate in replication
uh
this is just a story about modeling like
an example
so
okay
we started with two models one model is
simplified we called
body one
where we consider it
just a generation of virus particles by
cells after infection
and
the story
when the uninfected cells are infected
by
virus particles and so on so actually
the production of virus particle here is
constant
it not depends on
intracellular storage intracellular
processes another model which we called
ode5
takes into consideration this
intracellular story
and uh it generates a lot of difference
uh
okay this is just uh differential
equations
you can see that there are two models
they have
a shared portion
related to cells
and individual portions generation of
particles and intracellular story here
and
generation of particles will which
depends on inter
intracellular
story inside
inside cells so
virus replication
and
both wild type and defective particles
genomes
okay what kind of data we have
in order to to fit model to the data
we had
okay
the experiment was done
in two cell cultures
the raw and mosquito cell cultures
differently
in 12
passages
and the data which we have at the end to
fit the model are virus tighter
and
uh
next generation sequencing date
which also was used here in order to
to
fit the model
okay
as to
ode5 model
you can see that
virus particles majorities wild type
are
perfectly good uh fit to data here for
the raw cell culture and in
in mosquito cell culture
and uh
as to
next generation sequencing data
actually what we did is uh
what is called phylodynamics it means
that we created uh
haplotypes
so to say consensus of clusters
uh of genomes which appear in which were
assembled from the data
and
the
the request was
to fit coalescent
based
phylogeny
with the modeling with with with all
these processes of of
creating genomes and
eliminating genomes
in order to get
a good correspondence of coalescence
processes
cadets and phylogeny and
tuned to to the model
so
basically parameters of the model
were
tuned
with this type of data
virus title
and with this type of data together
the first interesting question is
both models are good for this or not
it appears that model the
simplified model or the
one is not good why
first some
important rate cell
cell birth
cell
multiplication of cells
a parameter
was unrealistic
in odf5 after
tuning to the data the model
demonstrated realistic value for this
parameter
and
here we can see that
actually
completely unrealistic this model in
order to be fitted to the data
fitted to to this type of data uh
was
gave a huge amount of
un uninfected cells
as a result
very different from odf5 model which
behavior is very good i mean that just
cells are dying
not not nothing specific in skepticism
with multiplication of cells
okay so
uh
obviously
it is very important to have this to to
have a model of this intracellular
processes in order to get reasonable
result
now the question is what is the
difference between
this interplay of
wild wild-type viruses
and
defective
their defective genomes
what's the difference between two cell
cultures
with the sensitivity
type of analysis we detected key
key rates so to say certification rates
of both
wild type
effective particles
defective genomes
rate of
protein production
and
rate of production of virus particles
uh
based on analysis of all
12
actually 11
11
11 passages we found that typically
values of these parameters are higher in
mosquito
and
mosquito is is
this fly virus is
actually
developed mosquito and
cell cell
mammalian cells are not natural
natural host for them
second
we try to answer the major question
the major question is
what's the role of defective particles
in all of them
what they are doing
can we say that defective particles are
therapeutic it means that there's a
saving
uninfected cells
or
this is not not not related not related
to any
attenuation so to say of viral infection
okay here what was done is
actually a jump from
modeling to biology
sort of
we took
based exclusively on this model
first we took uh
we performed variations of our
parameters of parameters of our moon
and for each
combination of parameters so parameters
are up and down 20
uh
we got some solution and this solution
looks like that this is time behavior
for for
here for the for instance
is
uh for
infected cells
and this solution like that is for
genomes uh defective genomes in in
in
cells infected by defective particles uh
and this is this solution is for
proteins
so uh first
based on
these observations
of modeling observations so
so the values of this curves
we can create a relationship between
solution and the different different
combination of parameters
and this relationship based on
conditional entropy
could be presented on the
svd plane
like
pca plane
and
we can see that
these points are
solution under different combination of
parameters
what is interesting we have some basic
solution
uh this basic solution when parameters
are most fitted to the data
and uh
most deviating into in two different
directions
most deviating solutions
so the question is uh
what actually it means the movement in
this direction and in this direction in
in understandable terms of behavior so
for behavior
we
sorry
we see
two components of this behavior
the height of the
height of the peak
and the pace of the process so this
process is faster than this one
so how we can interpret this picture
in these terms
and
it appears we can
it appears that we can
see that all parameters related to
defective particles
to processes
with defective particles
are
in in terms of peak height
are lower
then
[Music]
parameters
associated with a wire type
and more than that
parameters
which rules
behavior of uninfected cells
are here in the group of defective
parameters so to say
and when we change the direction
so it will be
right two direction here
this one and this one so
in this in this direction x movement
uh
we have
this sort of picture
and
in in opposite direction not opposite
but ordinal direction we have this sort
of function
what it means in terms of uninfected
cells
we can see that uninfected cells are
jumping together with
parameters
related to uninfected cells are jumping
together which parameters
associated with defective particles
like it's it's
it's
depicted here
so
we can say
and this is actually what we are saying
in in the part in the manuscript
that uh
defective particles
somehow
attenuating behavior of
uninfected cells it means the loss of
uninfected cells is attenuated by this
defective part
this is so to say a biological
conclusion major biological conclusion
from the story
that we found that indeed defective
particles somehow helping
not to lose too many uh
too many uninfected cells
okay and the next uh
next
so sorry so
here
i'm just saying that
acknowledgements
that this is people from tower center
professor antino and
our collaborator from institute pastor
in france
okay the next story i have
i have five minutes yes yeah
yes you have some time yeah
okay
uh this is like another story uh this
story uh about how to
introduce uh time
in in another in bioinformatics
informatics analysis of
uh
comics data in particular for for
instance single cell
gene expression data
or
uh multi-omics and physiological
features of
individuals in aging and so on
metagenomics data
so we have some observation but
can we present it as as a
time
time related potential so like like a
ball on the on the mountain
which can
go down
so where we have mountains and where we
have
[Music]
sinks
okay actually it was
it was great publication
of this sort
and we
expanded what was found in this
publication
that this potential for observation can
be
reconstructed
using
laplacian matrix
and if we know for instance stages like
aging stages or
single cell
differentiation
differentiation
stages for cells
so preparing a graph of some sort in
multi-dimensional space
and preparing this laplacian matrix we
can for observed observed
observed
cases we we can say what kind of
potential
uh
dynamic potential force field potential
we have along these cases
uh the next stage is
okay what we can say about point here
inside
and it means that we we
we
would like to prepare this surface
which will show that this is a mountain
and this is something
and
this stability stability state sync
could be related for instance to
old individuals with some illness and
here with just healthy old individuals
okay we we did it with uh
with the technique of uh partial
differential equations uh
and uh based on on
uh boundary values we restore
this
this surface
and as a result with this surface and
this is a projection of this sort so
this is a mountain now for any point
we can say
what what our possible trajectory and
what what are times
to go and probabilities to go over this
trajectory or over that project
and um
even in the case of
going from this
hole
to this hole
uh over the potential barrier like like
here
yes
and we can estimate what what what time
for diffusion
is needed in order to go here from here
to here
or in opposite direction so
from
from data
under condition of that the system is
stabilized
we can actually restore
time story
and
and since it can be applied to many
types of multi-feature data
i believe this is this is good
perspective to
to introduce this
time
time time axis in
and actually real biology
it means
to the multi-omics study
okay
this story was
done
by the team of tower bioinformatics
center in collaboration with professor
kudkov from roseville park comprehensive
cancer center buffalo
thank you
okay thank you very much for the
presentation and uh
you know i think it
follows some of the discussions that we
just had
and our next speaker is going to be
kind of addressing i think some of the
biological uh
parts of the story so
dr andino i wonder if you
had any
comments on this presentation that we
just saw
hopefully yeah i was
taking notes it's very interesting uh
the last topic it was uh you know
obviously the first topic is something
that it's very um well
we've been discussing this for a long
time with leonid um and i would i will
extend a little bit more um that but it
was a great introduction to
trying to understand how these um
defective uh genomes interfere with uh
the wild type and you know
can this be
um an approach for therapy so when i uh
make my presentation i'd like to give an
update of where we are on that uh in
manuscript that we are preparing on that
and that subject but i was very
interested on
uh the second part um and i have a
question
so clearly the the idea of time
resolution uh of these processes are
critical and i like the idea that you
you know descend a mountain um for a
mountain and in coming down from the
mountain you can take different path i
imagine
and the question is can we understand uh
that you know you're really going down
and can you anticipate what is this path
maybe we can interrupt this path and
that would be you know the more
practical um exercise here so how do you
train
that
model what kind of information can be
used to train the model and to
define better
whether they are common path if
everybody is taking the the
trail or people go
down the mountains and and in completely
random ways
uh okay the only thing
which you need is some stabilized system
and measurement of the system of multi
multi-dimensional measurements
and
so
the first step is to to understand how
uh
how
this
dynamic potential behave uh on
observations
and after that there's a surface
with known cases also who could be
reconstructed
and
as to trajectories
we actually can
based on parameters and parameters of
diffusion
we can estimate probabilities for every
project
based on of course based on these
parameters
and maybe it will answer your question
that some
trajectory will be with low
probabilities and the other projector
will be very very important
of course in the case of aging aging is
very probable process
but we have two direction
to be healthy or to be
uh
with some some illness
and as a very important question is to
to what direction we will go
starting freezing through from specific
point on the surface and second if it's
possible
for instance from from illness to go
back to health
very interesting
thank you